Дороги в Україні ремонтуються та будуються
надзвичайно високими темпами.
Принаймні, якщо вірити прем'єр-міністру України
Володимиру Гройсману. Дороги - одна з його найулюбленіших тем.
І ось чергова переможна заява:
Доброго дня, шановні колеги.
Ми у 2017 році відремонтували доріг більше,
ніж у  рекордному 2011 році, коли Україна готувалася до Євро-2012.
Якщо поглянути на промо-відео
обласних служб автомобільних доріг,
то дійсно складається враження тотальної модернізації.
Інтерактивна карта Державтодору показує, що
ремонтом охоплена вся Україна.
Підтверджує слова Гройсмана і статистика:
протягом 2017 року справді відремонтували 2177 кілометрів доріг.
Це понад удвічі більше, ніж попереднього року,
і навіть більше, ніж рекордного 2011-го, коли Україна
кинулася авральними темпами наводити лад
перед прийомом Чемпіонату Європи з футболу.
Проте, якщо звернути увагу на ширший контекст,
то стає зрозуміло: святкувати перемогу поки зарано.
Усього в Україні 170 тисяч кілометрів автомобільних доріг.
З них, за оцінками експертів, максимум 10 тисяч - у задовільному стані.
Тобто залишається відремонтувати чи реконструювати
160 тисяч кілометрів доріг. Навіть якщо Укравтодор
робитиме це на своїй максимальній, минулорічній швидкості
- на рівні 2170 кілометрів на рік, -
завершиться ця титанічна робота через 59 років.
Формально Володимир Гройсман не помилився:
2017-го в Україні дійсно відремонтували
найбільше доріг за останні 13 років.
Проте глобальність проблеми зводить це досягнення нанівець.
Попри рекордний показник, дороги в Україні
й досі в поганому стані. Були роки, коли
по всій Україні ремонтували лише 100 кілометрів автошляхів.
Крім того, фінансування постійно бракувало,
а сама ця галузь і досі вважається
прикладом тотальної корупції в Україні.
Український прем'єр обіцяє відремонтувати
всі українські дороги за 3-5 років.
Щоб цього досягти, Укравтодор повинен щороку
реконструювати по 32 тисячі кілометрів автошляхів,
тобто працювати у 12 разів швидше.